[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin schönen guten Abend zusammen
den sportlichen Teil der Sendung den
hast später du Norbert ja gerne ein
schönen guten Abend auch von mir dann
sind hier jetzt unsere Themen an diesem
Montag Landwirte auf den Barrikaden auch
in Frankreich ziehen wütende Bauern auf
die Straße und legen den Verkehr rund um
Paris teils
L Offenheit statt Abschottung
Bundespräsident Steinmeier arbeitgeber
und Gewerkschaften betonen rechtsextreme
Ideologien sein Gift für Arbeitsplätze
und
Wohlstand Handball in aller Munde die
Organisatoren der EM hoffen dank
vololler Hallen auf einen Schub für die
Sportart und das junge deutsche
Team viel geht nicht mehr in und um
Paris auch die Landwirte in Frankreich
sind unzufrieden mit der
Regierungspolitik desweggen heute zum
großprotest gerufen wurde und wie bei
uns solidarisieren sich auch andere
Verbände und Berufsgruppen mit den
Forderungen der Bauern deren erklärtes
Ziel die Hauptstadt lahmlegen dafür
haben die Landwirte wichtige Autobahnen
blockiert sie fordern bessere Bezahlung
weniger umwelauflagen und Bürokratie
außerdem besseren Schutz vor globaler
Konkurrenz obwohl die Regierung schon
signalisiert hatte ihnen entgegen zuu
hat das den Bauern nicht gereicht mehr
von Anne
ahend mit voller Kraft bringen Sie Ihren
Frust auf die Straße Landwirte aus ganz
Frankreich haben sich auf den Weg nach
Paris gemacht um ihren Forderungen
Nachdruck zu
verleihen es ist ein starkes Symbol
dorthinzufahren Paris das ist die
zentrale wo alle Ministerien sind alle
Politiker das ist der letzte Akt wenn
wir etwas erreichen wollen dann
dort der Innenminister hat für den
heutigen Tag 15000 Beamte
zusammengerufen um die Innenstadt und
vor allem aber den Großmarkt einen der
bedeutendsten europaweit abzusichern
immer mit der Maßgabe Ruhe zu bewahren
Blockaden nicht aufzulösen im Agrarland
Frankreich steht die Regierung einer
starken Lobby gegenüber 140 Punkte hat
der größte Bauernverband
vorgelegt als erstes müssen wir alle
unsere Haltung zur Landwirtschaft
überdenken ich verstehe dass sie
konkrete Maßnahmen fordern ich habe
Ihnen einige genannt und es werden
weitere folgen damit wir vorankommen
Woche für
Woche es ist die erste große politische
Krise für Gabriel Atal den neuen Premier
knapp di Wochen ist er im Amt seit Tagen
Rei er eilig von Hof zu Hof ebenso wie
die Rechtspopulisten die die Sorgen der
Landwirte zu ihrem Thema machen wenige
Monate vor der
Europawahl die Landwirtschaft ist eine
der Grundsäulen unseres Landes und wenn
die zusammen icht ist auch unsere
Souveränität in Gefahr und unsere
Versorgung mit
Lebensmitteln laut Umfragen unterstützt
die große Mehrheit der Französinnen und
Franzosen die Protestbewegung und so
steigt der Druck auf die Regierung nicht
nur durch die
Bauern Thomas Walde für uns vor dem
Amtssitz des Premierministers in Paris
Thomas bei uns ist die Politik den
Landwirten ja entgegenekommen wonach
sieht es in Frankreich aktuell
aus also hier ist die Regierung auch
schon den Landwirten sehr
entgegengekommen etwa bei der
Besteuerung von agrardieseln oder mit
der Einrichtung eines Notfallfonds für
Rinderzüchter und sie hat als sie
gesehen hat dass das nicht ausreicht
sofort angekündigt weitere Maßnahmen
folgen zu lassen man hält die
Forderungen der Landwirte durchaus für
legitim die Regierung will dieses Thema
nicht der extremen Rechten überlassen
Premierminister atall will eine schnelle
politische Lösung darum führt er heute
Abend hier in seinem Amtssitz auch
selbst die Verhandlungen mit Vertreter
Herrn der Bauern und die Regierung hat
auch die Polizei angewiesen heute etwa
nicht allzu hart gegen die Blockaden
vorzugehen für morgen wird bereits
erwartet die Verabschiedung Verkündung
eines neuen Maßnahmenpaketes auf
nationaler Ebene für die Bauern und es
heißt aus der Regierung Präsident macron
werde sich in dieser Woche auch in
Brüssel stark machen für französische
Bauern die eine Sonderstellung in der
französischen politischen Landschaft
einnehmen er werde unter anderem in
einem Gespräch mit Ela von der der
kommissionspräsidentin darauf drängen
dass französische Landwirte nicht 4%
ihrer Flächen stilllegen müssen Thomas
Walde live aus Paris vielen Dank mit den
bauernprotesten bei uns solidarisierten
sich ja auch viele andere unzufriedene
mitunter zeigte das auch wie verbittert
und unversöhnlich man sich gegenüber
steht Bundespräsident Steinmeier geht's
um den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
heute sprach er deswegen mit
Gewerkschaftern und
Wirtschaftsvertretern und gerade auch
vor dem Hintergrund bekannt gewordener
abschiebepläne von Rechtsextremisten und
den großen Protest dagegen für die sich
der Bundespräsident heute bedankte
Christian
Volk flaggezeigen gegen
Rechtsextremismus das haben
hunderttausende in den vergangenen
Wochen gemacht aus verschiedenen Teilen
der Gesellschaft unterschiedlichen
Parteien und auch aus Unternehmen ein
Stichwort der Proteste Zusammenhalt den
will auch der Bundespräsident fördern
organisierte ein Treffen mit
Wirtschaftsverbänden und en wenn unsere
Demokratie angegriffen wird dann muss
die demokratische Mitte die große
Mehrheit unserer Gesellschaft Position
beziehen und deutlich machen wir stehen
zu unserer Demokratie wir verteidigen
dieses Deutschland und wir lassen uns
dieses Land nicht von extremistischen
Rattenfängern kaputt machen wegen des
Fachkräftemangels braucht Deutschland
pro Jahr hunderttausende Zuwanderer
rechtsextreme abschottungspläne seien
eine Gefahr warnen die Gewerkschaften
als Sozialpartner sagen wir ganz klar es
reicht
deportationsfantasien
menschenunwürdige Äußerungen
Diskriminierung haben in unseren
Betrieben nicht zu suchen auch die
Handwerksbranche sei auf Weltoffenheit
angewiesen nur so könne Deutschland
Exportnation bleiben und deswegen ist es
so wichtig zwar das Ventil zu geben und
konkret zu sprechen wie die Ängste und
die Wut aufgegriffen werden aber die
Basis der parlamentarischen Demokratie
zu erhalten und miteinander in die
Zukunft zu tragen wie polarisiert ist
unsere Gesellschaft trotz Protesten
trotz AFD Umfrage hoch nicht so stark
wie etwa in den USA sagen
Wissenschaftler Leute die der extrem
rechten nah stehen das ist eine kleine
Gruppe und der steht eine in sich sehr
vielfältige und heterogene Mehrheit
gegenüber neben Protesten und Bündnissen
brauche es aber vor allem eine Politik
die versucht die verschiedenen Gruppen
zu
integrieren aufatmen bei Reisenden der
Deutschen Bahn seit dem Ende des
lockführerstreiks heute früh
normalisiert sich der Verkehr Fernzüge
fahren weitgehend nach gewohntem
Fahrplan im Regionalverkehr könnneen es
gebietsweise noch Einschränkungen geben
so die Bahn sie und die
lockführergewerkschaft wollen ab
kommender Woche wieder verhandeln
Streiks sind bis Anfang März
ausgeschlossen neue Einschränkungen
kommen aber auf all jene zu die auf den
öffentlichen Nahverkehr angewiesen sind
denn die Gewerkschaft werdi hat für
kommenden Freitag zu Warnstreiks
aufgerufen in allen Bundesländern außer
in Bayern Busse und Bahnen sollen
voraussichtlich den ganzen Tag stehen
bleiben in Berlin nur am Vormittag werdi
fordert für die Betroffenen 90.000
Beschäftigten vor allem bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen es war Ende November
da geriet das Firmengeflecht des
österreichischen Unternehmers ren Benko
in Schieflage dazu gehört auch die
kdwgruppe die jetzt Insolvenz anmeldete
zu ihr wiederum gehören vor allem das
berühmte Kaufhaus des Westens in Berlin
außerdem die beiden Warenhäuser
Oberpollinger in München und das
Alsterhaus in
Hamburg wir fragen jetzt walerie Haller
in Frankfurt an der Börse was bedeutet
die Insolvenz für die edelkaufhäuser
also zunächst die drei Kaufhäuser
bleiben geöffnet der Betrieb geht ganz
normal weiter und die 1700
Mitarbeitenden bekommen ihre Gehälter
durch die Agentur für Arbeit D Monate
lang gezahlt hier handelt es sich im
Übrigen um eine Insolvenz in
Eigenverwaltung diese Form der Insolvenz
setzt nicht auf Abwicklung sondern auf
Sanierung als Grund für die Insolvenz
gibt die kdwgruppe auch nicht schlecht
laufende Geschäfte an sondern überhöhte
mieten die entwickeln sich scheinbar zum
hemschuh soll nachhaltiges Wirtschaften
praktisch und möglich machen und
tatsächlich lief es auf Geschäftsseite
gut bei der KDW Gruppe in jüngster Zeit
mit mehr als 700 Millionen Euro war das
abgelaufene Jahr das umsatzstärkste
ihrer Geschichte und mit der Insolvenz
hofft die kdwgruppe sich von der hohen
mietlast zu befreien und günstigere
mieten aushandeln zu können ob das
gelingt ist allerdings unklar die
Immobilien gehören unter anderem der
signnergruppe und die hat ja gerade
selbsttinolvenz angemeldet vielen Dank
Valerie und Grüße nach
Frankfurt schon lange war der private
baauriese evergrand Chinas Staatsführung
ein Dorn im Auge wegen seiner Marktmacht
mit 10taus Privatkunden die ihr Geld oft
in Wohnungen angelegt haben meist Kredit
finanziert mit Corona kam dann die
Wirtschaftskrise die Kunden
zahlungsunfähig aber auch der Konzern
weil er selbst auf Pump baute ein
Dominoeffekt mit Schulden in Höhe von
fast 300 Milliarden Euro ein Gericht in
Hong Kong verfügte jetzt everagrand wird
zerschlagen Elisabeth
Schmidt betongerippe in Chinas
Urlaubsparadies heinan unfertige
evergrand Gebäude hunderttausende davon
stehen in China wie Geisterstädte
jahrelang baute evagrand immer mehr
Immobilien lieig Geld bei Gläubigern
jetzt die Zwangsauflösung per
Gericht die Anhörung hat anderthalb
Jahre gedauert und das Unternehmen war
immer noch nicht in der Lage einen
konkreten umstrukturierungsvorschlag
vorzulegen ich denke es ist an der Zeit
dass das Gericht sagt genug ist
genug Liquidierung heißt eigentlich
alles muss zu Geld gemacht werden um die
Schulden zu begleichen doch es ist
unklar ob das Hongkonger gurteil auch
außerhalb der Sonderverwaltungszone
umgesetzt
wird glaube jetzt nicht dass sich die
chinesische Regierung von einem
Gerichtsurteil in Hong Kong vorschreiben
lassen wird wie dieses Unternehmen
abgewickelt werden wird die chinesische
Regierung wird weiterhin sehr bedacht
sein die Auswirkung auf die Wirtschaft
zu minimieren denn die Immobilienkrise
wirgt sozialen Sprengstoff in China in
den vergangenen Monaten immer wieder
Proteste Käufer die befürchten ihre
bereits bezahlten Wohnungen nicht mehr
zu bekommen die Auswirkungen für die
Weltwirtschaft dagegen wohl erstmal
gering es ist nicht mit der lienpleite
2008 vergleichbar ich denke es wird
keine gewaltigen Auswirkungen auf die
Weltwirtschaft haben allerdings werden
Investoren besorgt sein denn die
Immobilienkrise in China ist noch lange
nicht bew
mit dem Urteil heute steht wohl aber
fest das Ende von Chinas großen
immobilienentwicklern ist
eingeläutet seit Tagen wächst die
internationale Empörung über
Enthüllungen zum unpästinenser Hilfswerk
UNRWA ein Dutzend Mitarbeiter sollen in
den blutigen Überfall vom 7 Oktober
verwickelt sein jetzt gibt es weitere
bislang unbekannte Details laut New York
Times soll ein mit Mitarbeiter an der
Entführung einer Frau aus Israel
beteiligt gewesen sein ein anderer sich
am Massaker in einem kibutz mit 97 Toten
beteiligt haben Claudia Bates in
Washington das sind neue ungeheuerliche
Details aber Vorwürfe zur Nähe zwischen
UNRWA und etwa der Hamas sind ja nicht
neu ja genau Israel wirft im Hilfswerk
schon lange Antisemitismus und
Verbindungen zur Hamas vor dass sie aus
den Einrichtungen des un-hilfswerk
angreife dass unterdessen Einrichtungen
die Tunnel der Hamas verliefen das UNRWA
besteht nur nicht aus lauter
internationalen Mitarbeitern der UN
sondern die rund 13 000 Mitarbeiter sind
zum allergrößten Teil Palästinenser die
in Gaza verwurzelt sind Verbindungen zu
Hamas streitet die Organisation aber ab
und verweist auch darauf dass Israel ja
Listen mit den Namen der Angestellten
des Hilfswerks bekommt und die auch
überprüfen kann nun hat dieser Skandal
die Reputation der Vereinten Nationen
erschüttert wie will man denn Vertrauen
zurückgewinnen ja die die betreffenden
Mitarbeiter wurden sofort entlassen
Generalsekretär guteres hat eine
Überprüfung angeordnet will sich morgen
auch mit wichtigen Geldgebern treffen
aber um das Vertrauen wirklich
wiederherzustellen bräuchte es
grundlegende Reformen neue kontrollm
Mechanismen auch gleichzeitig geht es
auch ohne das Hilfswerk nicht in Gaza es
betreibt Schulen medizinische
Einrichtungen und Millionen von Menschen
sind von dieser Hilfe abhängig danke
schön nach Washington Claudia Bates war
das für
uns die huthis im Jemen haben sich beim
Gazakrieg auf die Seite der
Terrororganisation Hamas geschlagen und
attackieren deswegen immer wieder
Handelsschiffe im Roten Meer der von
ihnen zum Teil kontrollierte Jemen der
liegt direkt an der so wichtigen
Handelsroute zwischen Europa und Asien
zum Schutz der Schiffe und als
Vergeltung beschießen die USA ihrerseits
Ziele im Jemen und bringen die his so
noch mehr in Rage das und der
Bürgerkrieg machen das Leben für die
Bevölkerung immer
schwieriger
berichtet der Krieg verschwindet nicht
aus den Köpfen der Kinder der kleine
Samir will seine Eltern und Brüder
Rechen sagt er sie sein in Jemens
Bürgerkrieg getötet
worden ich will kämpfen und mer werden
gott ist groß to Amerika to
Israel
diese Sätze die höre ich im Fernsehen
wenn es da um Gaza
geht Indoktrination der kleinsten gehört
zu den Grundlagen der hui Herrschaft
unzählige Poster preisen ihre getöteten
Krieger die oft noch wie Kinder Aussehen
vor der Küste Jemens haben die his
derweil erneut ein Schiff angegriffen
das ist der neue Krieg auf den sie die
Jemeniten eingeschworen haben
wir warnen jeden in Europa an der Seite
der USA uns anzugreifen wer das macht
der bedroht sich
selbst auf der anderen Seite der Front
die vom Häuserkampf gezeichnete
Millionenstadt t sie wird seit Jahren
von huthis belagert Einwohner erzählen
wie hi Scharfschützen immer noch auf
Zivilisten schießen und wie hthis die
Wasserzufuhr blockieren so dass fast
alle hier auf gespendete wassertrracks
angewiesen sind
die his haben uns so viel Leid gebracht
wir haben kaum Gas kaum Wasser alles
wegen Ihnen all diese Kriege hier sind
ihre
sch vertriebene ohne
Nahrungsmittelhilfen ein brüchiger
ungewisser Waffenstillstand und die
Verbrechen der his gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung seit fast ne9 Jahren
leben die Menschen im Jemen in einer
nicht enden wollenden Krise die
Eskalation im Roten Meer könnte eine der
schlimmsten humanitären Krisen weiter
verschlimmern in Deutschland ist wieder
deutlich mehr Falschgeld im Umlauf
Geldfälscher haben vor allem 200 und 500
€ Scheine unters Volk gebracht Polizei
Handel und Banken zogen rund 57 000
falsche Eurobanknoten aus dem Verkehr
das sind gut 28% mehr als im Vorjahr
laut Bundesbank sind viele Fälschungen
schlecht gemacht und gut zu
erkennen Tag war die erste japanische
Raumsonde Slim auf dem Mond ohne Strom
jetzt die gute Nachricht sie laufe
wieder und erkunde inzwischen die
Mondoberfläche meldet die japanische
Raumfahrtbehörde obwohl sie auf dem Kopf
gelandet war produzieren ihre
Sonnenkollektoren offenbar ausreichend
Energie um vorerst Daten und Fotos zur
Erde zu senden die sollen bei der
Planung künftiger Mondmissionen
helfen ja die Mission Olympiateilnahme
oder em Medaille für das dhbteam hat hat
nicht geklappt Frankreich ist
Europameister aber die Deutschen haben
trotzdem gewonnen auf jeden Fall dass
der Einzug ins Halbfinale das war ja
schon riesen Erfolg das junge Team
zeigte ein vielversprechendes Potenzial
und das Publikum eine massenhafte
Begeisterung die man so noch nicht
kannte Deutschland ist Weltklasse
internationaler Zuschauerrekord im
Eröffnungsspiel der EM im Düsseldorfer
Fußballstadion insgesamt sahen sogar
über eine Million Menschen die Spiele
vor Ort auch das ein Rekord viel Lob
auch aus dem Ausland für Stimmung und
Organisation der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft dagegen fehlt noch
etwas zum Prädikat Weltklasse dafür
scheiterte das Team zu oft an seiner
Chancenverwertung und ist gegen die
Weltspitze nur zeitweise auf Augenhöhe
das braucht noch ein bisschen Zeit und
ich glaube wir haben das Potenzial wir
werden glaube ich auch auch noch ein
bisschen besser werden hoffe ich
zumindest schon bald könnte sich
Deutschland wieder beweisen als Team und
Veranstalter denn Hannover hat sich
beworben im März eines der Olympia
Qualifikationsturniere
auszurichten gestern Abend Abschluss des
19 spieltags der Fußball buundesliga
Dortmund gegen Bochum der BVB mit einem
er mühsamen 3:1 vllkrugs Dreierpack sei
dank auf Niklas hülkruck ist Verlass
100% seiner Strafstöße landen im Netz
seit gut 5 Jahren so auch gestern gleich
zweimal gegen Bochum Überschwang aber
sieht anders aus ich denke wir haben
vieles gut gemacht natürlich auch noch
nicht perfekt aber wir sind weiterhin
auf dem guten Weg und meiner Meinung
nach war auch weiter ein Schritt in die
richtige Richtung das 3 Z1 gegen Bochum
bringt Dortmund immerhin den dritten
Sieg in Serie und in der Tabelle
erstmals seit November wieder auf einen
Champions League
Platz alle Tore alle Höhepunkte des 19
Bundesliga Spieltags zu sehen bei
zdfheute.de und in der ZDF heute App
Sterne des Sports das ist Deutschlands
bedeutendste Auszeichnung für das
gesellschaftliche Engagement von
Sportverein der Hauptpreis ging dieses
Jahr an den Thüringer Lac Eichfeld er
wurde von Bundeskanzler Scholz für die
Unterstützung blinder und sebehinderter
Menschen geehrt die Auszeichnung des
Deutschen Olympischen Sportbundes sowie
der Volks und reifeisenbanken ist mit
10000 €
dotiert sozusagen die Oskar des
Breitensports tolle Initiative das schon
seit 19 Jahren hab vielen Dank Norbert
wie es mit dem Wetter weitergeht gleich
von Ö den terli um
21:45 Uhr gibt's das heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka das war's von uns an
diesem Montag Morgen sehr gerne wieder
mit ihnen schönen Dank und für Sie noch
einen schönen
[Musik]
Abend schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter aus dem Südwesten
erreicht uns schon wieder relativ milde
Luft und auch eine Kaltfront spielt
morgen mit die ist aber wenig
wetteraktiv sehen aber hier in weiß es
kommen relativ viele Wolken mit in der
Nacht nach nordenin kompakte Wolken
sonst klart es auch vor allem nach Süden
hin und hier bildet sich der Nebel
genauso wie im Westen und das bei
tiefsten Temperaturen von -5° im
Südosten Deutschlands hier in Bayern und
7° ganz im Westen ja und morgen
Vormittag erst einmal im Süden durchaus
a dichter Nebel der löst sich meist auf
dann gibt's viel Sonnenschein so ähnlich
wie im Osten oder an den Alpen aber
sehen hier im Nordwesten kommt neue
Bewölkung auf und zum Nachmittag
bedeutet das dort wird es dann regnen
aber die Kaltfront die macht sich
hauptsächlich durch viele Wolken
bemerkbar ja und die Temperaturen dazu
bei 6 bis 13° das ist natürlich viel zu
warm für die Jahreszeit wir schauen auf
die nächsten Tage am Mittwoch dann
kompakte Wolken und meist trocken bei 6
bis 13
Donnerstag dann nach Süden hin viel Ring
und Freitag nach Nordosten hin damit
einen schönen
Abend